the bureau went so far as to mail  anonymous letters to dr. King and his  wife which were mailed shortly before he  was awarded the Nobel Peace Prize and  finishes with this suggestion King there  is only one thing left for you to do you  know what it is you have just 34 days in  which to do it this exact number has  been selected for a specific reason it  has definite practical significance it  was 34 days before the award you were  done was taken by dr. King to mean a  suggestion for suicide was a nice  understanding now if you had received  such a letter  how would you have interpreted that what  would you have thought it meant I have  read that statement I have heard the  conclusions of your staff that it was a  suicide  urging I can't find any basis upon which  they drew that conclusion I think that  approaching it from an objective  standpoint as I read it I don't know  what it means